your dog is the best you go on long
walks together
cuddle up on the couch and enjoy sloppy
kisses
you really love that pup but uh what's
going on there does your dog
love you back
first let's address the bigger
philosophical question
does your dog love anything can your dog
love i think that you know in many ways
we could apply the same criteria to dogs
and other non-human animals
as we do to human animals that's mark
beckhoff
he spent a lifetime understanding animal
minds from coyotes
and wolves to domestic dogs like yours
and he says dogs probably think and feel
similar to humans a lot of new research
on neuroimaging using fmris
is showing that the same parts of
dog brains and human brains light up for
example when
um they're feeling jealous so really the
difference between how your dog feels
joy and other emotions and how you
experience them
might be like the difference between you
and another human
so dogs can likely experience what we'd
think of as
loving relationships and studies show
that dogs are pretty good at building
relationships with us
too comes as no surprise one study found
that dog brains are highly adapted to
recognize human faces
and interpret our social cues so maybe
that's why your dog is always extra
sweet when it knows you've had a bad day
but are those puppy dog eyes just for
you or is your dog pretending to love
you
for you know food and that i think is
really ridiculous are there dogs who use
people for certain things well i'm sure
there are just like there are people who
use people for certain things
but i don't think that that would
characterize the overall nature of
dog human relationships so yes your dog
can love you oh all right great uh we
can all go home
um no just because they can
doesn't automatically mean that they do
each dog is a unique
individual and it's not one size fits
all
some of the most brutally abused dogs
i've met
who took months to even get them to make
eye contact with me
and or other humans have the capacity to
love
but you had to earn it it wasn't just
sort of
here it is no you had to earn their
trust and like everything worth having
in life that trust will take
time and work but it can be done
you sometimes just go good dog when
they've quote done
nothing and i say good dog to dogs all
the time and people go
well why did you do that they didn't do
anything and i would always just say
because they're alive and they're good
dogs they're just
it's like i don't know it's like human
beings saying to a good friend
i love you or i'm really glad to be your
friend
and don't worry you'll know when you've
earned your pooch's trust
do they follow you around you know do
they just hang out with you not only
when
you're feeding them or walking them do
they follow you around do they seek you
out
do people tell you you know if you will
when you're not there that they
wander around having wanderlust you know
is it clear that they miss you oh yeah
checks out that's a happy dog so can
your dog love you
absolutely does your dog love you well
that's on you
[Music]
if you want to learn more about how your
dog experiences the world
check out mark beckhoff's recent book
canine confidential
why dogs do what they do